o rap rap rap devagar devagar vai rápido
o bar
está seu corpo
[Música]
é
porque gravar vídeo eu posso fazer Olá
pessoal daqui aí carai ou já diz procura
o quadro de pessoal daqui quem fala é o
daqui seja muito bem vindo já mar
mais um vídeo eu hoje trago-vos aqui no
jogo que eu não sei qual é porque está
no menu ainda igual pessoal escusado
será dizer que este jogo é de terror e
portanto vamos fazer aqui uma coisa
diferente Ok vamos tentar tornar isto um
desafio é Um Desafio tá aqui lançado o
desafio não sei falar ainda mas tá agora
o que é que eu posso coisas no desafio é
eu achei aqui encontrei um desafio
pessoal olha aqui olha aqui a minha
pistola dos cães ter já tive aqui em
reunião com ovelha negra
bate uma polêmica já que é João pessoal
o desafio é o seguinte cada vez que uma
testar o Avenida vai colocar Qual a
quente onde pode ser na perna ou no
braço não no braço não podes aqui não
carro aqui olha aí
na sua perna certinho uma bola uma
bolinha a uma tira uma parte né Isso
aqui é uma tira assim é uma linha mas no
final eu vou dizer mentiras não é certo
vou ser eu a boa pode ser vai embora
vou tentar ler em Português volume até
chegar aos grilos Batista Angry lá que
o
movimento tivesse penso na folga suas
fechada tá muito perceber está aqui
controles rito desliga o [ __ ] altura
uma das e minha ordem pessoal o jogo
chama-se Spinner é o ingles tem que ser
assim com a língua porque Clay tutorial
é isso eu gosto de aprender a jogar o
joguinho logo pessoal estamos Nem
esquenta com o resto do Castelo do
[ __ ] não sei que é isso que eu essa
dito no chifre de três principais
desapareceu
funciona funciona a fica encravado Ai
meu Deus que é que eu faço agora vou
carregar um espaço que é para fazer
Cláudio viram como eu percebo isto left
Mouse Black tanto a internet e hip-hop
Jackson para interagir com objetos é o
rato a sério automóveis um a interagir
com a cadeira para ai ai temos interação
que eu estou isso não funciona este
mentiras agora como é que eu faço aqui
carai tô no estado e sabe espaço faço aí
eu clico chaminé é que
é
eu abri o gabinete e agora chegou e isto
quer dizer que vai dar um bicho atrás
bem já já sei já conhecia este alguém
decoração aqui bateu Olha lá
você vai achar exatamente vejam como
este jogo é intuitivo e fácil pessoal
vai sem já é free
tutorial efeito like comente depois Já
cheguei já tá bem Concept demo este
modelo não é então é pequeno que tanto é
bom é bom pequeno Optimus pode também
levar a [ __ ] somos por um jogo será
opções boa Play conserto demo eu ainda
não acabei agora o papai agora pessoal a
partir de agora o que susto qualquer
desejo de 616 de susto nós vamos colocar
nós não eu toda se vocês né eu vou
colocar uma pistola de cola quente na
perna eu vou colocar também pode ser
tudo olha aí por favor e já luz a luz
para normal baixo Olha eu não sei onde é
que eu não consigo tem luz tem luz mas
tá aquela luzinha sabem com aquela
textura é aquilo que terror sabem é essa
é a
não estou só aquele aroma enxofre ou
traseiras adoro cadeirinhas Ai ai
mamãe e uma lanterna vou passar um
barulho aqui ó
[Música]
ó um bicho aí
eu deveria seguir
e o traiu tem olha ai que tem uma mancha
de sangue pessoal fujão estrela estrela
é o sangue podem na textura do teto
pessoal eles têm Isto é construção ao
mais alto nível tem que ganhar mas tem
que uma pessoa que vai estar para abrir
também e só não sei que estavas falou
não vai aparecer susto agora ou tomar
tentar continuar máximo pessoal turma
conter o máximo não levar susto estou
aqui para te ouvir Isto é
só
colocar o pé ele demônio e
Oi Lu meu preço tá morrido
foi isso como é que ela precisa estava
bem longe vai expor a cola quente já até
ejacular realmente sabem como é que fala
e vai mexer a cola agora vai mete mete
mete mete rápido rápido rápido devagar
devagar vai rápido devagar
mas não encosta mas não encostou com
muita força muita força a [ __ ] vai
vai papai muito morro puxava logo a
e não chega chega chega chega a estar
digo é não não lá embaixo aqui olha que
eu penso que eu vou assim mamãe vai
fazer como é que foi Deixa de ser menina
[ __ ]
[ __ ] a funcionar não é que ele tá bom
então
[Música]
vamos lá o jogo ainda não acabou Espera
aí começa de novo já vai aparecer aqui
agora né já não aparece mais aqui a tem
que apanhar Flashlight que eu tiro são
tudo pega sol já peguei a lanterna agora
vai aparecer né
é uma testou Avaré
mesa agora já fui amanhã por aqui né
porque já saiu o jogo já conheço está
aqui perguntar
me
manda foto dele só que eu te pego tu eu
também uma vergonha foi oi já não
aparece usando o que é isto não tem
qualquer coisa aqui não sei aí ele tá
vírus conta Estou vindo aqui no meu set
pronto eu te ligo o outro lado era já
consigo passar aqui que já consegui já
abriu já abriu aqui já abriu aqui perder
vai acho que vai ser o pessoal já tô não
sei que eu nunca fui até aqui pessoal
vamos lá não vai sem susto em susto
cargo é a perna estava ali ó
eu vou subir a escada agora agora agora
pessoal
Ronaldinho não
sei o que é que eu tô fazer mais resulta
o pessoal resultou num sítio que eu não
conheço vai dar susto vai dar bosta aí
não sei que
estão
precisa ter um pé de cabra é isso que eu
não fui aí pertinho tipo tem o que para
nós foi uma chave para Rua Abril Abril
Abril O que é que o gerador pega só isso
que eu vou matar uns Ah pois tu foste o
pé-de-cabra para aqui né Vai espera está
muito mal feito esconde esconde esconde
na verdade um o caraio não se vê nada
que lindo como é que é possível vou
passar eu vou passar hoje não deixa tem
que baixar baixar isso ai pessoal estou
tão fresco aqui
aí agora eu
já te dou o gerador agora tem que ir lá
para cima outra vez né
Isso aqui é
isso Acabou o preço para o jogo foi só
isso só mais um susto mais uma linha de
cola Olha aí ficar tão que estás a
pingar tudo sozinho olha aí a foto posso
vai vai vai vai rápido não chora não
puxa assim logo também é
E aí
o
[Música]
bruxo hora pai eu não tenho três vai
três vai coloca 33 vai contra o teu
querer conta conta conta de Cristo
pois também doida logo pessoa tem doido
doido é tu é
E aí
o
123456789
ela é muito pelo eu não vou contar Poxa
todo
olha aí queimado Olha aí queimado
puxava o resto o resto falei olha aí eu
vou medir aqui olha olha o pelo que eu
arranquei é só
puxar mais puxa mais vai passar essa
aqui vai lá
é só para isso não poupa mais um portal
onde isso queimado Olha aí queimada
[ __ ] quando é queimado vai deixar eu
vou te matar porque eu vou aí
me
arrumei o [ __ ] lá isso só pelo
depilação em aplicativo é pelo na perna
não agora vamos ter Cola que irá acabar
fala agora existe uma olhadinha no teu
colo e
o bonde sexual mete mais [ __ ] Isso
mete assim logo mesmo também mas mesmo
assim mas
novo gel Pessoal espero que tenham
gostado já sabem quantos cavalos likes
favoritos aqui vai até a próxima